دموع فتاة تبلغ من العمر 15 عامًا تقول
إنها سارت للتو عبر الحدود
لمقابلة والدتها ، لكن والدتها
أغمي عليها للتو ، وهي لا تعاني من أي نبض ، فهي لا
تتنفس
مسعفين متطوعين من الإسرائيليين
يتنفسون لكنها لا تزال
فاقدًا للوعي.  بحاجة إلى مستشفى ،
يستغرق وصول سيارة إسعاف 30 دقيقة ،
لقد أنقذت حياتها ، هذه هي الحياة على
الجانب البولندي من الحدود مع
أوكرانيا ، النساء والأطفال فقط
يأتون
بعد ثلاثة أيام في البرد
على أمل بولندا وحسرة القلب في
كل مكان كما  اللاجئون يحزمون في
البلد ، فرت أولغا من البلاد مع
ابنتها أنجلينا أولغا البالغة من العمر تسع سنوات ، واضطرت
إلى ترك زوجها خلفها حتى يتمكن من
القتال بكل ما يمكن أن يجده
صعبًا للغاية ، ولا
أستطيع أن
أخبرك بمدى صعوبة هذا الشعور
بأنك تفقدك.  الحياة التي
تعرفها وهنا
لم أكن أعرف ماذا أفعل فهي لا تزال
مصدومة من الصدمة ولكن على الأقل لديها أصدقاء
ليأخذوها مع حلول الليل في البرد القارس.
يقدم الناس
للاجئين ترحيباً حاراً بملابس
دافئة مكاناً دافئاً ليبقوا فيه وجبة دافئة حتى
حفاضات الأطفال وألعاب الأطفال ، وهو
جهد شعبي وسط
ساحة انتظار سيارات في السوبر ماركت على بعد بضعة
كيلومترات فقط من الحدود ،
يشبه والدي فعلاً مساعدة المدينة  أن تحب
التمسك بالأرض
ومثل هذا
تمامًا وأنا أحاول المساعدة قدر
المستطاع وفكتوريا هناك طالبة تقول إنه من
المفترض أن تدرس من أجل
امتحاناتها النهائية في الكلية لكنها
لا تستطيع التركيز عليها  هذا في الوقت الحالي
لأن
هذا الأمر أكثر أهمية بالنسبة لها لمساعدة
بلدها على التطوع لجعلهم يشعرون
بالترحيب لأن عائلتها
لا يزال والدها ووالدها في أوكرانيا يقاتلون من
أجل بلدهم
ولإعطائك فكرة عما هي عليه والآخرين.
يفعلون هنا أنهم يتأكدون من أن
كل من يأتي عبر تلك الحدود
ويصل إلى هذه المنطقة على بعد بضعة
كيلومترات لديه كل ما
يحتاجه ليشعر بالترحيب
سارة سيدنر سي إن إن
بولندا